this young woman let's call her le isn't
feeling well but she doesn't go to the
doctor's office he comes to her via an
app called Babylon health
hello hello there this is dr. but from
Babylon thanks very much for choosing us
for your consultation today how can I
help the last few days Ellie explains
that her eyes itch mabashi are botched
is a general physician and at Babylon
health he also chooses the doctors who
provide the services digital
consultation antihistamines just
over-the-counter ones our service is an
on-demand service so as soon as a
patient books an appointment the next
available doctor is allocated to that
patient so the patient cannot
necessarily select a named doctor but
they are able to see the names and
details of all of our doctors on our
website a long distance diagnosis by the
next available doctor users of the
popular app don't seem to view that as a
drawback although it's only been on the
market a few months the london-based
firm already has around 100,000
customers
behind the scenes that the app developer
the atmosphere is relaxed the team is
made up of experts from around 20
different countries it was put together
by founder and CEO Holly Parsa exactly
what is the problem you're just trying
to keep these guys in suspense right
parses vision has a lot in common with
out of other digital startups it is so
much we could do to make health care not
just simpler and more accessible but
better and that's that's all a our aim
is to do with health care what Google
did with information to make it
available to everyone everywhere
patients can also receive written
consultations and the app can track some
bodily functions consultations are
erased from a patient's phone and the
doctors computer after every session
babylon employees IT experts to make
sure the system is secure the reason we
have to go through all these steps is
medical data is incredibly precious a
lot of people are trying to access it
illegally our patients have a right to
make sure that their data is secure and
safe so we go to a lot of effort and
time to make sure that we're protecting
the data at all times well just to
summarize then Eddie I do think it's hay
fever rather than I infection I'm
prescribe the sort of the three things
it's nothing serious otherwise Ellie
would have been advised to see a doctor
for a physical exam well the developers
believe their approach to medicine has a
bright future I think the potential for
digital health care to benefit patients
globally is huge it has huge potential
to be able to help patients where
resources are scarce and where doctors
are scarce dr. Watson zeliha digital
prescription and she can pick up the
medication at any pharmacy
was there any other questions that you
have to at all great okay well thank you
very much indeed for using Babylon bye
bye bye